-My next guest is a dancer,
singer, actress,
and social-media superstar.
I mean, seriously superstar.
She has 32 million followers
on TikTok
and over 12 million subscribers
on her YouTube channel.
She works hard.
She deserves it.
She's currently working
on a new project
that she is announcing tonight.
I can't wait.
Here is Jojo Siwa!
-Hey!
I'm so excited!
Thank you for having me.
-Welcome back.
Thanks for being here.
I know it's over zoom,
but we appreciate it.
We have so much to talk about.
-We do.
-One of the things
I love about you
and your fans love about you
is that you are always yourself.
You're always you.
-Yes.
-And you're always leading
by example
and spreading positivity,
very positive.
-Thank you.
-And you continue to do that
now more than ever.
Two weeks ago, you posted this.
You opened up about being
part of the LGBTQ community,
and immediately,
love started pouring in
from all over the world.
How does it feel?
Where were you in your head
at the time?
-It was the most
insane thing ever.
I mean, literally everyone
and their brother messaged me,
called me, texted me, sent me an
Instagram message, tweeted me.
It was the most love, I think,
I've ever received,
and the coolest thing about it
was it was just by me
showing the world
the last little piece of me
that they haven't seen yet,
and it was really awesome.
-Did you plan on doing it?
-So, that's actually
what's funny about it.
So, I was doing TikToks
with the people
who are in the Pride House.
That's, like, what their
TikTok house is called,
is the Pride House.
And I love them.
I've known them all for years,
and so we were like,
"Let's just do
some TikToks together
before I leave for Canada."
And they come over,
and we're doing this TikTok,
and I was like,
"I think this TikTok that we're
doing to 'Ain't It Fun,'"
I was like, "I think this is
gonna out me."
And I was like, "I don't really
mind, because it is true."
I do have the most amazing,
wonderful, perfect
most beautiful girlfriend
in the whole world.
It's not something
I'm ashamed of.
I just haven't shown
the Internet yet.
And there's always been
speculations, of course,
but so then I was like,
"I think this is gonna out me."
So then I posted that --
they posted that,
and, of course, it did,
and people started commenting --
and people started commenting to
me, "Is this you coming out?
Like, is this you coming out?
What is this? What is this?"
So I was like,
"You know what I can do?
I can either mess with them
and, like, tease a little bit,
I could either confirm it,
because it is true,
or I can just kind of
do nothing about it
and just kind of
leave it there."
And I was like, "I want to do a
TikTok to 'Born This Way.'"
'Cause it is true.
I don't really want to be like,
"Yeah, it's true," right away,
but I was like,
"I want people to know that,
like, it's okay."
So I did this TikTok
to "Born This Way,"
and everyone was like, "Whoa!
This is her coming out!
This is the moment!"
And I was like, "I..."
And then, my cousin
had gotten me that shirt.
I took that picture
like a week before
I posted it,
and I actually -- I put it on
my close friend's
Instagram story,
and all my friends know,
all my family knows.
And then, one day, I was
on FaceTime with my girlfriend.
This is the day after I posted
the "Born This Way" TikTok.
And I was on FaceTime with her,
and we were just
talking about it
and talking about all the love
that came in,
and we were both like,
"Technically, I still haven't
confirmed it."
And so I was like,
"I kind of want to post
this picture on my real story."
And she was super encouraging.
She was like, "Do it."
and I was like, "All right!"
And I did it.
And the funny thing is,
is 10 minutes before I did that,
you can only imagine the
press storm that was happening.
I mean, it was insane.
-Yeah.
And 10 minutes before I posted
that, my publicist was like,
"So, are you gonna confirm it?"
and I was like,
"No, I'm not gonna
confirm it yet."
10 minutes later, I post that
picture and start texting her.
I was like, "Hey.
So about not confirming it,
go look at my story."
-"It's out."
Did you -- Did you --
Did you put your phone down?
Because you probably go like...
Either way,
you're gonna get feedback.
You're gonna get good stuff,
and you're gonna get bad stuff.
-Totally.
-And you know it's gonna
start a conversation.
-Yeah.
-And you're like,
"Once I press this button..."
-There's no going back.
-Yes.
-My thing with "coming out" is
it can be a very scary thing,
you know?
Of course not everybody
in the world is going to
accept it right now,
but there are so many people
that are going
to accept it right now.
And like I say, even if there's
a million people --
say there's a million people --
that's a lot of people
that don't accept it,
there's 100 million that do.
And I think that's something
really important.
100 million is a lot of people,
and so always keep that in mind.
But, also, I was like,
"I don't want it to have to be
such a big thing."
Like, what am I gonna do?
Like, have a coming-out party?
No, it's just who I am.
And so, after I posted it,
I was just kind of like,
"All right! I'll do it." Like,
I was on the phone spontaneous,
like, 'cause she --
we're long-distance,
and so I was like,
"All right, I did it."
Back to FaceTiming with her.
And then it was like
two days later,
I was again on the phone.
We're on the phone
literally 24/7.
Both of our families get so
annoyed at us, but it's okay.
It doesn't matter.
But I was like,
"You know what I realized?
How risky that was."
And she was like,
"Well, what do you mean?"
And I was like,
"Well, technically,
that was a really big risk
that I took posting that."
But I was like,
"But honestly --"
And she's like, "Why? Because
you could've lost everything?"
And I was like, "Yeah.
But if I lost everything
that I've created
because of being myself
and because of loving
who I want to love,
I don't want it.
That's not what I want
if I can't love
who I want to love."
That's one of the most
important things to me.
And it was about 10 minutes
before I came out
to do this interview today,
I was again on the phone
with my girl,
and I started crying.
And she's like,
"What's wrong with you?"
And I was like,
"I'm just so happy."
I was like, "Because now
I get to share
what makes me the happiest
with the world,
and it makes my heart so happy."
-There's a lot
to be happy about.
I want to congratulate you,
because you were named
one of Time Magazine's 100 Most
Influential People of 2020.
Now, you are 17 years old
and one of the most influential
people on the planet.
-Crazy.
-How does it feel,
and do you feel different?
-Isn't that crazy?
I mean, it is insane.
I don't feel different.
I mean, nothing changed,
but I guess I didn't really
realize what a big deal it was
until I actually saw the list
and saw the other people
that were on it,
and then I was like, "Whoa.
Like, this is a huge honor."
And, I mean, it's insane,
and I'm so thankful,
and I'm so grateful.
Actually, something funny
that came from it is,
we created a new game in my
family and my close friends.
So, my best friend, Nate,
we made a game
where I try to influence people
to do something.
And it's the smallest things.
So, say we have a whole bunch
of pizzas, and I'll be like,
to somebody, I'll be like,
"Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, the cheese is good,
but the pepperoni,
you gotta try the pepperoni."
And if I get them to do it,
Nate and I look at each other,
and we're like,
"Time 100, baby!
Up top!"
-"That's how influential I am.
Look at how influential --
He doesn't even like pepperoni."
-We try.
We try so hard, and it works.
And it's -- well, all the time,
we're like, "Top 100, baby.
That's me."
-Yeah. Why not?
I saw you did something
over quarantine,
because obviously, we all had
to cut the tours short
and all this no live events,
and, you know, you --
when you're a performer,
you have to perform.
We've had people on the show,
comedians going like,
"I just miss it.
I have to.
It's part of me."
-Yeah.
-And you did something
very cool.
You built a stage
in your backyard.
-I did, I did.
So, my mom was watching people
perform, like,
from their living room,
and I was watching people
perform from their couch.
And I was like,
"I want to see a concert."
And my mom was like,
"You should do one of these."
So, that was kind of
where it came from, from me.
I was like, "I want to do one."
And my mom was like,
"You should do one."
And I was like,
"But I -- I can't."
I was like, "I can't sit
on my couch and sing a song.
It just doesn't --
It doesn't work."
Like, I literally
don't know how to do that.
I say all the time, "I'm an
Ameri-can, not an Ameri-can't,"
but, like, I can't do that.
And she was -- she was like,
"So then don't."
She was like, "Build a stage."
And I was like,
"Well, all right."
And so I started looking
on Amazon, and I was like,
"All right," I have
these platforms in my cart,
and I was just gonna, like,
do it for one week.
And then I was like,
"This still doesn't feel right."
So I message my friend who
kind of just can do anything.
And I was like, "Hey.
Do you have a guy that could
help me build a stage?"
And she was like,
"Yeah, let me get on it."
-[ Laughs ]
I love it. Two seconds --
"Yeah. Of course."
-Two seconds.
She was like,
"Yeah, yeah, totally."
And so now it turned into
this whole thing,
and it's so awesome,
and it's so incredible.
I did it every Friday.
I think I did --
I think I did 12 of them and
then a few dance videos, too,
and it was just so much fun,
you know?
And we put on full-blown shows
of singing and dancing
and lights and music
and a stage and costumes.
-Good for you.
-And it was just --
It kept me so happy.
We would shoot, like,
three of them in a week,
and it just, that week,
I was always the happiest human.
-Speaking of costumes,
you have one of the biggest
empires of consumer products.
I told you my girls
are fans of yours,
and so we have
bows all over the house,
we have headphones
with bows on them, we have --
Your books, by the way,
are fantastic.
-I love it.
-We -- It's just --
I think they kind of
started writing diaries.
But I think I've read somewhere
you've sold over
80 million hair bows.
Is that wild?
-It's crazy.
It's so incredible.
I'm so thankful.
I mean, my mom and I
actually have been selling bows
for much longer
than people think.
I'll never forget when I was --
I think I would've been
5 years old --
4 or 5 years old --
we used to go to our local,
you know, haircut places
or little boutique stores,
and my mom told me, she was
like, "Here, you carry them,
'cause you're cute and little,
and they'll want to buy it
from you."
And I was like, "Okay!"
So, we're walking in
with our little basket of bows.
And we tell the people, "Hey,
do you want to buy some bows?"
And this one time, they're like,
"Yeah, we'll buy it.
We'll buy 10 of them."
And my mom and I,
we were, like, so pumped up.
We walk out of there
with 100 bucks,
we're like,
"We're going shopping!
We're going to lunch,
we're going shopping!
It's gonna be
the best day ever!"
And so now to think that
that 10 bows
has translated into 80 million,
I mean, that is insane
and amazing,
and I'm so thankful
and so grateful.
Because of what
the bow stands for, you know,
being yourself,
being kind to everybody,
to think that there's
80 million of them out there,
it just --
it makes my heart so happy.
-You've accomplished so much,
and you're still a teenager.
What would you say
is your ultimate dream
or another dream, another goal?
Something you haven't done yet
but you know one day you'll do.
-Oh, man.
I -- Yeah.
My biggest dream, and it's
coming up this weekend,
is to play the Super Bowl,
to do the halftime show
at the Super Bowl.
I have seen
every single one of them.
I mean, from Jackson --
Michael Jackson's
Super Bowl show
to Gaga's Super Bowl show,
I think is probably
my all-time favorite.
J.Lo's incredible.
I can't wait to see
The Weeknd this year.
-Let's get him on the phone.
We can get you --
The Weeknd --
Let me call The Weeknd.
-Beep boop boop!
-Yeah, I'll call The Weeknd,
we'll get you a private plane
to Tampa, and --
-Tell him I'll do a little
"Blinding Lights"
for him on stage.
I got it. I got the TikTok.
I got it.
Let's go.
-Yeah. Of course, yeah.
-Oh!
-We can totally
get this happening.
-Yeah.
-I can see you on that stage.
That is --
-Thank you.
-All right, let's put it
out there in the world.
It's gonna happen.
-I'm a believer.
I'm a "You believe it,
one day..."
I might be 80 years old,
"Coming to you live
from Jojo Siwa's death bed,
here we go!
The Pepsi Halftime Show!"
[ Both laugh ]
-You're wheeling out.
You're still doing
"Blinding Light."
♪ Do, do do ♪
"Yeah, that song is old now."
Yeah, we're...
But you have a big --
You have
a big announcement tonight.
-I do.
-Can you tell everyone where you
are and what you're working on?
-So, I, right now,
am in Vancouver, Canada,
and I am so excited, me and
my friends at Nickelodeon,
we are making a musical,
and I'm so pumped up about it.
This musical
is centered around my life
and also centered
around being yourself
and centered around
staying true to who you are,
and even when the world
is telling you
that it's not gonna happen,
it's not gonna happen,
you're believing
because you're you.
And that's -- that's what
this movie is all about.
And the music in it
I'm so happy about!
I have worked
so hard on this soundtrack.
There's six original songs
on the soundtrack
and then two of my old songs,
but one of them
is like a full revamped --
remix, and it's so much fun.
But from the six original songs,
I created 27.
Had to narrow it down to six.
So it's been a process,
but it's been so much fun.
Now that we're actually here,
it's happening,
we've been in quarantine
in rehearsals.
We have an incredible director.
We have an incredible writer.
Obviously, my friends
at Nickelodeon, it's --
Aah! I'm so excited!
-It sounds amazing.
Do you have a title?
-We do. We do.
It's called "The J-Team."
-"The J-Team"!
I'm on The J-Team!
-You're on the J-Team!
Jimmy's on the J-Team.
-That's you.
-See, people think it stands
for The Jojo Team.
It's really
the Jimmy Fallon Team.
Don't let it fool you.
-That's what I'm talking about.